I got a Robert handler here with me I'm
Andy Belmont uh we're doing with your
hot tips video about how to sell your
stuff how to sell your stuff because
we've had the discussion and it's like
okay here's my menu Rob you could sell
this anywhere right what's what why are
we doing a video about where to sell
yourself because there's so many
merchants why not just sell dump off
your stuff wherever you go it's a great
question and the answers that is certain
things certain items and certain
merchants are selective in what they'll
take and what they'll give you as far as
crowns go for instance you got all these
books right you read the ideas you read
every book some of them have some some
value some bestiary knowledge or some
skills anyways you like here I mean this
happened to me and I think every person
is if you start backing up all this
stuff and you gotta get rid of it
yeah and there were moments where I was
like you know I'll just drop it all no
no no no laughs it was too late for me
but like I've wasted too many books just
by dropping because I was overburdened
but turns out I didn't know about it
there is a librarian here in higher ed
right novigrad hierarchs square this is
like my opinion like kind of the go-to
to like just like you got basically
everything you need here for the most
part you got a couple merchants you got
an armored nearby there's a blacksmith
someone over here we'll get to that
later but yeah there is a librarian here
and it's you know it's not as much
because we I compared it earlier uh yes
um it's not as much as you'd you'd hope
for but regardless it's just a nice way
to know all these crowns add up uh oh
yeah and you want it you want to you
know get a rhythm going and holy you
know you notes are just crap right you
read a note and you can just seriously
toss it from those part of the book some
of these are like that's real money
hefty like look at this thirty-five like
that adds up right like here's two four
you know 180-day um and you tested this
the other merchants that actually accept
books accept it at a much lower cost
than this dude so yeah you're talking
you're talking like two to three crowns
this guy
give or take like 10 ish um so let's see
here let's actually look at one these
books compare yeah I need to offload
like tons of books on my my guys so yeah
right I'm going straight to this dude is
there any other book do you know like in
novigrad or sorry in scale guy or
anything no section so this is an
earlier safe - like say I was like
alright I remembered this this save mine
where it was like just backed up and
crap yeah but I you know I'm at almost
20 and I recently got to scale Jaeger
and I haven't found any other librarian
order guy so this could be the only one
regardless it's a start
so see here this book how to avoid
colossal vessels for me that's something
you don't really need as a butcher no
you don't it's not which I am back I am
back that size books of yours sell them
books sell it for thirteen which is
pretty good hmm I mean compared to what
two or three from merchants um so yeah
that's basically the librarian
definitely worth your time alright you
showed me another one though that was
key because you'd you end up getting a
lot of trophies right and you can only
actually have one active at a time
because it hangs off your horse whatever
right um as far as I know you can never
get more than one so you have all these
excess trophies you kinda want to sell
them because they only sell for like
five or like really low but you found a
dude right it actually gives you pink
dude Bank and it's worth your time and
there's it's interesting because you
know we've heard about these like
roundabouts with like cows right of ways
of making money yeah and they've patched
that now with the monster so you could
you know you could kill a bunch of cows
and basically um keep spamming that but
now they've added a monster that'll come
up and kill you to prevent it but uh
there's this guy right here near the
Oxford oxenfurt gate um he's an
alchemist
alright and he will give you so trophies
if you look and we'll take a look in a
second uh trophies can go from like
anywhere like 50 to like three hundred
crowns I mean that's what it says that
right value is in your inventory but
when you actually try and sell them we
asked you guys well you guys crap from
like and
merchants I mean alchemists as far as my
knowledge goes like alchemist will take
a higher amount than like higher amounts
than like other just normal dudes
leveled merchants yeah but this dude up
here in the hill Roach he is legit like
full price that's awesome it's awesome
yeah so you want to hit this guy up and
yeah you said it right like eventually
you start you know what you've probably
knocked out like a dozen to attend like
trapeze you got yeah I get rid of them I
mean they're stinking up your bed right
oh yes
Mike dead decay non-stop coming from you
I mean that's part of the Witcher code
you just have to smell like [ __ ] right
uh so here's like a famous one the night
Wraith for 300 ham 1050 is what you is
what the value is and some of me some of
these I just don't even care about like
like noon race and I race are kind of
like a dime a dozen yeah exactly like
dismemberment like as much as I love
dismemberment like the next guy you're
there's no value to it in my opinion I
mean you're gonna have those instances
happen um I always go for like XP bonus
motion on humans and humans like a
that's tight you're you're winning in
that respect and if you're short on cash
maybe you want to use like bonus gold
you also got there's one down the road
that haven't I read about it's like XP
from monsters that you kill yeah be cool
so like you know you you want to save
like one of each of my opinion just like
three heads uh and just kind of switch
them in Matt in and out in and out
excuse me whenever you want so anyways
this is the guy right here oddly enough
he kind of went um anyone comes up
certain side he only comes out at like
certain times so
oh you're gonna be meditating a lot and
I believe it's from 12 to 6 p.m.
how did you learn about all this stuff
from our lovely sisters like GameFAQs
like oh that's basically it babe I was
playing and I had these drugs you know
you're just like damn like where can I
go to get rid of them and here's your
man this is like the only guy no but I'm
sure there are other two snakes
I mean it's really so freaking cute
anyways these will be sold 300 OPM full
price like legit right yeah
salad and you depleted him of his gold
so right so that's the issue with
merchants too is I found this out like
last few days ago so he's you know we
max him out it's so funny to think about
but like so overtime merchants will you
know go through their own inventory like
you you hit up an merchants you sell
them out you take all his coin over time
he will accumulate it all back or just
random stuff so today's figure how
roughly how long it takes yeah I read a
couple differed like a day some
merchants will make back like 125 crowns
mmm I've heard other things where it's
like if you do this like 10 times he'll
I'll have money back alright so you
gotta really put the brakes on your
quest for ciri hopefully she doesn't
grow old by the time you're done farming
where have you been
I forgot to donate and everyone else
does but now I'm rich or just like
walking by Jerrold it's like dude this
guy's been like kneeling down for like
10 days you're right better okay man
he's always in doubt bro she's feeling
it so see ya well that's cool what other
like items do you have that you can like
match up with a certain merchant yeah so
I kind of looked into that as well but
I'm just curious to see what this guy
made okay see that that was like four or
five days
which or days really think yeah that's
roughly 300 yeah got them down to three
now they already say you know so another
thing if you're desperate you do it but
you know I in general like that's fine
you know you don't have to like spam
your meditation like you just come hit
this guy up once in a while and get you
full price so they add you were talking
about different things so I actually
originally thought Oh swords you sell
too so like every merchant just your
typical merchants they're all like
different um so I have some saved games
here that are worth looking at okay cool
so here is like an instance and II we're
like you got two merchants one over here
no no beer I know this guy do you yeah
yeah he like got scared when like some
novigrad cops showed up rolled up but
you take care of the need yeah sells his
stuff I mean obviously you're not gonna
like rat him out like he's got something
to give so like for instance here the
sort I had this sword here is worth 383
at him I know in general in general okay
so let's check them out special silsila
for shall we trade let's do it baby
this guy 93 okay alright it's pretty
good in this one 322 that's real good
pretty good you think right
so then you got this random merchant
here this bum right I just find this
interesting and it goes to show like the
difference in merchants yeah this girl
he's got her he's just got empty bottles
baby yeah empty bottles next to the sea
and you take a look at Rimmer what he's
got what he'll take for 383 which was 93
from the other merchant yeah and this is
like 15 that's full price dude so the
other thing is that it's real
interesting but the issue is that as you
can see he's only got 6 9 25 but he's
he's just like did I'll give you my kid
he's gonna give all his money for that
sword he'll do it and again this is
another thing which like keep this guy
in mind you can easily you're like
looking to dump off you just see the
first merchant you go to that guy yes
the street yeah and you just say yeah
that's all right that sounds good like
whatever right and then you go you don't
even know you're getting half half or
leave unless like some dudes it's
bizarre it's all just really interesting
didn't it's like fascinating like
different versions will just be like I
got so much [ __ ] like sorry Bob is there
a logic to it because seemingly like you
wouldn't be able to tell that guy could
give you more money like based on his
looks and where he is like there's no I
don't think there is either right like I
think it's just these merchants are just
bizarre and it's worth checking out yeah
like you know know like I think the
habit should be like alright
no one item know what you have so you
don't have to always constantly go back
into your inventory and compare you know
items but like know what you got and
then just you know when you see a
merchant check them out and just compare
or something that you're familiar with
any back all right this guy's legit
he'll give me fairly high price for that
like that's insane like 6:59 I mean yes
I'm out and you could you could if you
have the time and patience you could
just meditate forever right and this guy
could slowly make money like so I did it
he had 625 right I did like four this is
a save I had so I did like four days
cycles and that's what he came to and
before he was like 500 so
if you just keep this dude in mind and
you played at the game and you know you
come across these items that you know
are really high in value you just always
hit this dude I'm just getting rid of
him full price and that was for like
swords but what are the Pirates did
there was a discrepancy between like
other items that you know he was doing
everything everything was hide oh yeah
we can go back now show you like that's
awesome so I wrote all these down for
like different versions right so he's
kind of like a quote-unquote magic
merchant how how many other magic
merchants do you know I don't so this
guy was just random I just randomly
found him um so here is like six-six 80
he'll give me this um ah Triglav rune
stone now I look back the last merchants
would give it for 260 yeah uh an armorer
would give me 409 and a blacksmith would
give it to me for 409 so again like
armors and blacksmiths Earl they're good
they're the same I had the suspicion
like also like you know my armor to the
armor cuz you don't he's into that ya
know like blacksmiths and armors
interest if you're looking to sell items
to roughly the same in my opinion um you
know I can show fees what does this guy
want for the trophies damn full price so
he's maybe just like a magic merchant
yeah or something like that uh I guess
so
well that's awesome awesome right yeah
so there you go actually you know screw
meditation if you're like not into that
you could get rid of you know your
trophies and and your hot items to this
dude yeah that's about it man let's send
people on their way
yeah stay tuned GameSpot if you want to
see more stuff about videogames cuz
that's what we do huh that is what we do
thanks Andy yeah thank you
you